there's one aspect of formation which is
repetition
and morphic resonance is really a theory
of repetition and habit
it says that once new forms have
appeared
the more often they appear the more
likely they are to appear again
so that helps to explain form uh the
appearance of repetitive forms and after
all most things we see are the
repetitive
it doesn't explain the first time
an oak tree appears the first time
there's a feather the first time
was an eye the first time there's a star
or galaxy or a zinc atom
or a hemoglobin molecule
so there has to be an evolution as well
a principle of creativity
a creative principle whereby new forms
new patterns can appear
we know they do appear um now how we
explain creativity
is a big mess physical question and
there are several alternative answers to
it
i leave it open because it depends very
much on people's
worldview yes i think that there are
fields that organize social groups and
i've looked at these in
animals because all social animals have
social fields they all have to
coordinate
members of the group and when you look
at flocks of starlings for example which
we have here in england and winter huge
flocks of
up to a million birds they fly around
before
dusk and the whole flock can change
direction
almost immediately without the
individuals bumping into each other
they know not only where the others are
but where they're going to go
and the same is true of schools of fish
and so there's something about animal
groups that they can be coordinated by
some kind of invisible connection
and the best computer models of these
flock behaviors
treat them as as fields as if they're a
bit like iron filings in a magnetic
field
i i think this would be a a brilliant
way of testing norfolk
i'm not a gamer myself and i don't know
people who
program games but if i can help
someone's opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we
and what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host alan sakhyan
i'm so excited to be talking about
morphic resonance we have dr rupert
sheldrick joining us on the show
hi rupert hello alan thanks so much for
coming on the program
i am very pumped for those who don't
know rupert's a background
rupert is a biologist and 16-time author
slash co-author best known for his
hypothesis of morphic
resonance which posits that natural
systems inherit
collective memory he has studied
developmental biology and plant
physiology from cambridge to hyderabad
most recently fascinated with
unexplained human and animal abilities
you can find his links in the bio below
sheldrake.org as well as his youtube and
facebook pages check those out
rupert i have absolutely loved
where you've been coming from these last
couple of decades
i think that what you're putting out
into our world
is extremely necessary for this big
picture synthesis of science and
spirituality
and also for it to give us a more
clear metaphysical picture of what the
true nature of reality
really is so that is the ultimate first
principled question and so you're really
put putting putting energy towards
unleashing that at its fullest
let's just jump right into morphic
resonance because
i messaged you about this and it seems
to be
one of the most pressing questions
around
the question of metaphysics in the sense
of
how is it possible that a
pattern of activity like a seed
contains all of the trunk the branches
the leaves the fruits
and then it is also recursive as it has
more seeds
how does a zygote contain the embryo the
baby the child the adult
and the potential for more humans
recursion
how does the big bang contain all the
matter stars planets civilizations
and the potential for more big bangs
recursion
and there's no dna during cosmogenesis
that dictates this morphological
development
so the question we ask is what is the
information what is the pattern the
underlying habits unfolding
across these examples how does it work
rupert how does it relate to
morphic resonance well there are many
forms in nature
um atoms of forms molecules of forms
crystals reforms
plants and animals planets stars
galaxies
all of these are forms in the sense that
they're organized self-organizing
structures of activity
and clearly at the moment of the big
bang there were no forms the universe
was totally amorphous
so all these forms have come into being
as the universe has evolved
and the same is true of an egg i mean
the big bangs like the hatching of
cosmic egg you know
um it's kind of mythic the modern
scientific myth
um but if you think of an embryo a
zygote a fertilized egg
that doesn't contain much form either
and yet you and i
have eyes and legs and arms and spleens
and livers and so on
um none of those are in the fertilized
egg more forms appear
so both in individual development
ontogeny
and in phylogeny the evolution of life
and indeed of the entire cosmos
more forms appear from less now
in the case of living organisms like us
then the forms that appear are
repetitions of what's happened before
every time an oak tree grows it's like
previous oak trees
you and i are like previous humans in
many respects
um the every time a new star
forms it's like lots of other stars um
so there's one aspect of formation which
is repetition
and morphic resonance is really a theory
of repetition and habit
it says that once new forms have
appeared
the more often they appear the more
likely they are to appear again
um so that helps to explain form
uh the appearance of repetitive forms
and after all most things we see are
repetitive it doesn't explain the first
time
an oak tree appears the first time
there's a feather the first time there's
an eye
the first time there's a star or galaxy
or a zinc atom or a
hemoglobin molecule so
there has to be an evolution as well a
principle of creativity
a creative principle whereby new forms
new patterns can appear
we know they do appear um now how we
explain creativity
is a big mess physical question and
there are several alternative answers to
it
um i leave it open because it depends
very much on people's
worldview if you're a materialist and
you think there's nothing but matter
and chance uh giving rise to the
universe then
there's no higher purpose in anything
it's just chance
and um but if you think there's a
guiding
consciousness under underlying the whole
of nature the whole of the universe
then there could be creative mind or
minds at work in this process
i'm not talking about a kind of
intelligent design where it's all done
in a kind of like an engineer on a
drawing board
i'm thinking more of a creativity that
spontaneously takes place that
makes things up as it goes along anyway
that's another theory of creativity
but basically morphic resonance is a way
of explaining the repetition of forms
and what i'm suggesting is that the dna
that's inherited in the zygote
has a limited role in inheritance it
doesn't do everything most people assume
that
genetic is synonymous with hereditary
uh it isn't um what the dna does is
enables organisms to make particular
proteins it specifies the sequence for
amino acids and proteins
like in your hemoglobin or in the
keratin in your skin and so on
um you need proteins and all the enzymes
we have
um dna explains that kind of inheritance
or at least the primary structure of
these proteins
there's also epigenetic inheritance the
inheritance of acquired characters which
affects the expression of dna
of genes but most of the inheritance of
form and of instincts
um i think is working through morphic
resonance through this kind of
collective memory principle
excellent okay so let's
let's play off of where we
in a sense it was it's it feels as
though it's a little bit like
uh plato's theory of forms and ideas to
a certain
extent and also it feels as though
there is a deep connection between that
and what you were mentioning
regarding creativity and imagination
and also the uh as
john von neumann called the the
universal constructor
and so there there's something that
that is inherent in
the cosmogenesis that then
downstream creates
these mutations in the tape that then
which we as co-creators we
influence those mutations
at one moment the imaginative idea of
seeing
birds and then thinking we should fly
across oceans too
and then all of a sudden every
generation
after that has access to flying across
an ocean
in half a day so
we make these mutations along
along the way and it's almost as though
it's a it's a
forms and ideas and imagination and
creativity that cause that
okay yes okay well you see i think
what plato was saying is that there's a
realm of forms or ideas that gives rise
to everything in this world they're a
reflection of ideal archetypes or forms
however um he thought those i archetypes
were totally transcendent in a kind of
mind beyond universe what i'm saying is
closer to what his student aristotle
thought
aristotle thought that the forms were
actually within nature they were the
souls of living things
so for plato every horse is a reflection
of an eternal horse idea beyond
space and time for aristotle every horse
has an invisible horse soul which shapes
its body as it grows as an embryo and
underlies its instincts
and so all the so it's not outside
nature is in nature
and for him soul was a natural causal
organizing principle every living thing
had a soul and he thought that many
things were alive including magnets
and the earth and the stars um
so um what aristotle was saying is
closer to what i'm saying is within
nature
and it's um but he like plato
didn't think in terms of evolution this
is a much more recent idea
um so the idea that they didn't think in
terms of a memory in nature they didn't
need a memory in nature if you've got an
eternal
uh forms outside nature or inside nature
that are fixed already
you don't need a memory you just take
that for granted
but if things are changing as time goes
along
as the evolutionary model suggests uh
indeed it's basic to it
then the idea of memory becomes much
more important because
these forms are not just um
manifestations of eternal ready-made
forms
they're based on adaptations to what
actually happens
organisms are shaped by their
environment and they can inherit
adaptations
and so it's not just an eternal
principle
now rupert let's touch on
you said earlier epigenetics i think
this is very important i think it's also
very important to see where we can go
beyond
epigenetics with morphic resonance so
in terms of science and understanding
epigenetics this was a
profound advancement actually rosalind
franklin
um francis crick james watson i think
that
um since 1951
to 3 i think that since then it's only
been
about 70 years and we've had now
a profound um transition
into what is now going to be the
biotechnology
age in this next decade and beyond
where we'll have things like a constant
stream of our bodies biometrics and
we'll be able to make tweaks like
like jets that have hundreds of sensors
on them and we'll be able to also
increase our longevity and retain
youthful homeostatic capacity
and that's all to the thanks of
understanding this code of life
and also to how to augment it and uh so
this is very profound
and and i i wanna explain briefly
that the idea of epigenetics that these
newly acquired behaviors
leave things like dna methylation and
affect histone tails and that's passed
down to future
generations and that's not just
behaviors but that's also things like
the traumatic instances as well and if
you do things like
heal what has been a trauma in your
lineage
it you can actually butterfly affect
that downward and outward
uh and i think that's that's very
profoundly important
cells also have very
interesting processes like this with
their
cell cycles and their checkpoints and
where they also have if they have a
certain amount of
protein that's built up that it may be
indicating that it was harder to
have mitosis happen so there is a memory
mechanism even at the cellular level
and you were mentioning this earlier as
well that a lot of what
the the
was a very profound enrichment that
happened from carl jung's work with the
collective
unconscious and archetypes and
dating back to what we were talking
about with plato and aristotle
and their mentality around this
this is this is extr this has been now
triangulated on from so
many different angles in terms of
what is truly underlying in a
maybe a sort of implicat as like a david
bohm would say or
some sort of a source code or or an
or uh an animistic essence
of sorts and and what what
is that rupert that is beyond
epigenetics
well epigenetics as is currently
understood epigenetic inheritance
is the way in which genes can be
switched on or switched off by
methylation or changes in histones
or whatever it's conceived of
in molecular terms that's
one reason it's the taboo against the
inheritance of acquired characters
was lifted around the year 2000 in the
20th century it was one of the most
taboo topics in biology you could
lose your job and you suffer serious
career damage if you said you believed
in the inheritance of quiet characters
no it's okay um it's a major shift
um so um that's a welcome
change uh but it things can go further
you see
now let's take an example um
if you train rats to learn a new trick
um this is one of the experiments for
morphic resonance
yes um it's this experiment's actually
been done it was started at harvard
decades ago um you train them to learn a
new trick
and it turns out that their children
learn it quicker and their children even
quicker
and it went on over 30 generations them
getting quicker and quicker
um and this was interpreted as the
inheritance of acquired characters
because it was
from the parents to the children and
this became
very controversial research because of
the taboo against inheritance of
acquired characters
then someone did a control experiment
they
tested rats that had whose parents had
never been
trained in this trick and they found
they were getting better too
they were all getting better so it
wasn't
just something passed on through the
genes or modification of the genes
there was something else going on and
that's i think where morphic resonance
comes in
so i think in inheritance we've got
several different aspects to inheritance
we've got dna
which explains the structure of proteins
and some of it's concerned with
switching on and off other genes
we've got epigenetic inheritance that
can silence or
activate genes and that can be passed on
in some cases we've also got morphic
resonance
and then of course we've got cultural
inheritance and that too
can involve morphic resonance when a
baby learns a new language a language
for example
i think that it's not just a stimulus
response psychological process i think
that that
learning is accelerated by morphic
resonance
so um it underlies cultural inheritance
as well
now would it be fair then to say that
it is potentially both like you just
indicated there is
a a tremendous amount of the
the current scientific paradigm that
is that like you just described
unlocked the the next level of
understanding
genetics and epigenetics and so we have
this
general understanding now and the way
that
that process is part of this this
uh the the in
the inheritance of of memory and then
we have something else that that is at
play
which you've cited the example with
learning with rats but there's also
many other you you give you give so many
other
examples um with with dogs knowing when
their owners come home
with with nursing mothers and that
their their them being able to feel when
they have their uh the the breast milk
and their babies
and the need to feed you you there's
there's many of these sorts of examples
this kind of is also a little bit
leading us into um the the science
and dogma section a little bit but i i
wanna i wanted to just ask especially on
i wanna know if there's
both if both these both coexist you kind
of gave the indication that you have
on on a on a body level you have
the genetics and epigenetics and the
further understandings of science
and then there's also some sort of uh an
implicat
or an ethereal or a spirit or soul or
animistic
source code-esque um contribution and
those two things can co-exist
well yes i think that i don't think it's
sort of
ethereal exactly at least it depends
what you mean by ethereal but i think
it's a field i think these things work
through what i call morphic fields
yes and morphic fields are fields
and um in science we have quite a number
of fields
and there's the magnetic field around
the magnetics you can't see the magnetic
field
it's in the magnet and it's around it
the gravitational field around the earth
it's an invisible organizing structure
that keeps the moon in its orbit and
keeps us
down on the ground then there's the
electromagnetic field of your cell phone
which is
active inside the cell phone but extends
invisibly beyond it
and um now all of these are fields and
the point fields were first introduced
into science in the 1840s
they're not part of the original
newtonian mechanistic picture
and most of our modern technologies are
field-based technologies i mean
right now we're talking on zoom the
whole of this works on electromagnetic
fields and transmissions and so on
so i think morphogenetic fields probably
the form shaping fields and morphic
fields which is the generic term to
cover
form shaping fields and behavioral
fields and social fields
i think these are actual organizing
fields invisible
organizing structures their patterns or
regions of activity
in space and time and so it may sound
the fact they're invisible and they
organize things invisibly
some people would say oh wow this must
be pseudosciences
and so on but actually that's the basis
of the whole of modern science the whole
of modern science is explaining the
visible in terms of the invisible
and once you get into quantum matter
fields and
quant zero point energy field and the
higgs boson field
uh we're dealing with a whole range of
fields which
underlie reality they're invisible they
give structure and order and form to
things
morphic fields is another kind of field
we've already got several kinds within
science
but i don't think it's yet an exhaustive
list
yeah you give these those are very
important examples
in the not only earth's
magnetic field the gravitational pulls
the all the technology in the last 150
years is
now functioning off of these invisible
fields to the human eye this is very
important but also
even further more when you look at even
just something as simple as a tree
the tree is not just the static tree
there's a massive field around the tree
that is constantly doing the
the o2 and co2 exchange that is it's
just
happening all over with from the leaf
sections
all the time and if you're next to it
you're inhaling that and
exhaling so you see like you're there's
so that's also a big funny thing with
the whole identity thing if you identify
yourself as just your ego
or if you identify yourself as also that
tree
that's a little bit of a separate thing
but you you give also this really
important point about
social groups i think is very important
like you just listed there's just
there's something else happening so
we're going to coexist these concepts of
genetics epigenetics
and the way science is understanding the
collective inheritances of of memory
but we're also going to add to that
picture
we're going to add to that something
else that is that that's occurring
across a morphic field for
humans and there's got to be ways to do
this better i mean
we'll give this brief example in sports
and then i'll i'll make the
the question here but just
it's so true that in social groups
there's almost some sort of a a morphic
field that happens if you've ever been
around
especially in like northern california
what happens is you have
an extremely um
homogenized perspective about a specific
topic
and you basically can't you can't really
enter a new
idea into like a social group if there
have a homogenized idea
and with athletes there's something
going on with athletes
and myself and one have played for so
long different sports
especially in team sports where there's
some sort of a
collective intelligence that's happening
that is
it's it's in a sense it's it's some sort
of an extra sensory perception
and there's something going on between
the teammates where they're able to be
in complete
surrendered flow to communication
and sharing so ultimately rupert what we
can have science do to further prove
this
is more randomized controlled trials
around
how our capacity to quickly
learn around the world new ideas
and so this can be a way for science to
further probe and understand that
with all these examples
um yes well looking at social fields um
yes i think that there are fields that
organize social groups and i've looked
at these in
animals because all social animals have
social fields they all have to
coordinate
members of the group and when you look
at flocks of starlings for example which
we have here in england in the winter
huge flocks of
up to a million birds they fly around
before dusk
um and the whole flock can change
direction
almost immediately without the
individuals bumping into each other
they know not only where the others are
but where they're going to go
and the same is true of schools of fish
and so there's something about animal
groups that
they can be coordinated by some kind of
invisible connection
and the best computer models of these
flock behaviors
treat them as as fields as if they're a
bit like iron filings in a magnetic
field
each individual iron filing is not doing
the organizing itself it's within a
larger structure
of which it's part and i think members
of social groups
are like that i think that's why
you were talking about a kind of
consensus views that you get in
societies i mean
scientific paradigms are like that
thomas kuhn pointed out
that with at any given time scientists
share a common model of reality a
paradigm
um and anything that doesn't fit in is
dismissed or ignored
or treated as heretical but then there's
a scientific revolution
and another paradigm takes out over
another model of reality
um and then the same thing happens again
i mean
his model of scientific revolutions was
rather like
sort of old-style latin american
military
dictatorships where you have a kind of
dictatorship that's replaced by a
different dictatorship
it wasn't scientific revolutions have
involved replacing one dictatorship of
ideas with another they haven't
none of them's yet been like the
declaration of independence where the
sort of
democracy hit science uh we're still in
the old
model of uh you know at any given time
and right now the dominant world view is
mechanistic materialism
it's coming apart at the edges and it's
as i show in my book sunset free called
the science delusion in the uk
um these dogmas of materialism are
actually being outgrown by science
itself we're going beyond them
so there's there's a sense in which
social fields constrain
our thoughts they also link us together
and in team sports
um they can lead to this coordination
that's
sort of unconscious and almost
automotive sort of automatic and
michael murphy looked into this you know
the founder of the
esselyn institute who's very keen on on
looking at sports as an evolutionary
phenomenon
and in his book the psychic side of
sports um
co-authored with rio white he um
talks about how interviewing he
interviewed american football players
and a lot of them felt they were sort of
telepathic with other members of the
team
but none of them did say so in the
locker room uh because they thought the
others would think they were weird
um but this is going on all the time i
think
in in sports activities and
it's this connection between members of
groups within the social field that
underlies
telepathic phenomena like dogs knowing
when their owners are coming home and
mothers knowing when their baby needs
them
when they're miles away from the baby so
i think we're linked together with
members of our families and members with
other social groups through these social
fields
ultimately this is our responsibility
to create randomized control trials to
probe this
we can let's okay let's jump into um the
the dogma of of science so
you you've said this so well in the
science delusion
and also in uh you know in science set
free
that the we need to
free the spirit of enquiry and that's a
just a superb way to put it and
another way to put it that i've really
enjoyed is the idea of
of of of being able to
parse and identify where the baby is in
the bath water
take the baby out and drain the bath
water and
and the same thing's true for
spirituality in the sense of
we got to drop the dogmas and
fundamentalism in both science and
spirituality and we have to
and we have to prop up this spirit of
free inquiry
and and also the idea of polymaths or
heretics or just people that are trying
to plant a flag
beyond like here's an idea morphic
resonance okay great
it's beyond the edge of science like
we've planted this flag
beyond the edge of what we know the
here's the perimeter
and so the idea is now we have to make
randomized control trials we have to
make
it's a hypothesis it's a theory and now
we have to test it
and and the idea is that if you just say
no no no it's not possible then all
you're never
actually that that's dogma that's not
pursuing
science that pursuing science is making
actual steps towards that flag and
there's many of these
flags that we can plant outside of the
edge of what's known
and so this is really the idea of
propping up the baby and draining
the the the bath water and i i also
really liked a lot how you put
the idea of of habits rather than laws
in a sense because we just in in a sense
we don't know
if things like the gravitational force
uh the
gravitational constant or the the
constant of the speed of light
or rupert if we're orbiting the center
the black hole in the center of the
milky way every 225 million years and
we're
going through patches of dark matter or
dark energy
or if there's different um solar flares
happening from our sun or the
gravitational pull from jupiter or
saturn or there's a biochemical
change that's happening in the center of
the magma of the earth
or if there's one species on the planet
that's causing another species
to to to cause
us to feel differently when we eat honey
or
something there's so many things that
that we don't
know that nature you gave this really
good example like imagine if
the journal nature or cell or science or
whatever
if if they just had a like a yearly
section or monthly section where they
reported
like the weather or like the sports
scores they reported
the scientific uh habits
that have been changing because of
what's
going on in in the the field
of existence so i really thought that
that was
so eloquently um given a visual but
d do you really do you really feel just
one more example here and then i'll hit
it back to you
with artificial intelligence rupert
there's a very interesting
way to understand there's a great
analogy here
where we have now
uh artificial intelligence perception
we're talking about a lot we're talking
about the second cambrian explosion in
in in perception and what's so
interesting is that when
when like a fleet of teslas
is driving and then the
the tesla one of them goes through a
very specific
pattern of activity that they that the
collective intelligence that had not
experienced before
what happens is as soon as that tesla
goes through that process
of learning from that unique novel
experience
what it does immediately is it updates
the collective database of all
tesla's knowledge so i love that
analogy in a sense of how fast a
collective intelligence of artificial
intelligence perception can
learn and there's some sort of analogy
there with humans especially that we can
scientifically test
how is it that if somebody learns
something across the planet
that somebody else in a different
country
across the planet can learn that faster
yeah yes well um yeah i agree the
this artificial intelligence thing which
has this built-in learning
which is shared um is a bit like morphic
resonance and
collective memory and that's why it's so
powerful of course
if you just rely on a programmer
programming things with no learning
uh then you know they get it right they
get it wrong it works some of the time
but this one actually learns and adapts
as
new situations arise and that's much
more like evolution and much more like
the collective memory
in morphic resonance in terms of
what you were saying earlier about uh
controlled
experiments uh to you put out a flag to
some new hypothesis and then yeah
do experiments this is of course what i
actually try to do
my time is spent doing experiments and
um to try and explore these
new areas and let me just describe two
experiments which i'm doing at the
moment because they're ones that anyone
who's listening to this can actually do
and i'm always trying to recruit
new subjects and since we have a captive
audience at least
i don't know how big the captive
audience is this is an opportunity i
don't want to miss
um i've got two experiments online on my
website sheldrake.org
at the moment um one of them is
a joint attention test and here i'm
exploring something
i don't think anyone else has ever
explored it's it's um
the question is if you have two people
concentrating on the same thing at the
same time
oh nowadays with me mass media we can
have millions of people
concentrating watching the same tv show
for example watching the same
football match um millions at the same
time
is there a kind of resonance between
minds when people are watching the same
thing as someone else
this hasn't got a standard scientific
word i i call it joint attention
we know we know that joint attention
actually joint attention is established
because
when babies reach the age of about one
they become capable of joint attention
and it's a very important part of normal
development
that's why with people with babies and
toddlers they go around they'd say
doggy and they say oh yes doggy and and
you it's joint attention on the same
thing
is essential for human development uh
proper if people who don't have this
turn out to be autistic very often
so it's about our shared uh world anyway
in my joint attention test um
you log on online and with another
person
um in a separate place and then there's
a series of trials where in each trial
you're showing a picture
you're just watching the screen a
picture appears and
at random your partner may be sharing
the same picture or a different picture
there's a different pair of pictures for
each test
um each car lasts every 10 seconds the
whole
whole test lasts three minutes so um
then uh what you're asked after 10
seconds
one of the people is asked was your
partner looking at the same picture
okay and you click saying different
you're right or you're wrong by chance
you'd be right 50
of the time yeah in these experiments
it's coming out significantly above
chance it's not a very big effect but
it's very significant
are we talking 55 60 what are we talking
about we're talking
in this case only about 53 54.
over thousands of trials it's okay it's
it's very significant
yeah and anyway i'm doing a new test
comparing different kinds of pictures it
seems to be working better when you're
looking at
pictures of faces than landscapes for
example
perhaps because it's more interesting
so that's one of my experiments looking
at a new phenomenon
and then of course i want to scale it up
what happens if you've got 10 people
looking at the same thing yeah
50 or 100. and of course you could do
this live on tv as well where you could
do it with millions
yes yes this would have an enormous
effect in interpreting what's happening
in modern culture which involves huge
amounts of joint attention
yet this is completely unexplored
because the standard materialist
assumption in science is that minds
are nothing but brains and they're
insulated inside heads
so what you're thinking and looking at
has no effect on me
at a distance because that's impossible
your mind's nothing but the physical
activity of your brain
the second experiment that i'm running
which i invite people to take part in
is an experimental test of telephone
telepathy
more than 80 percent of the population
say that they've had experience the
experience of thinking of someone
who then rings and they say that's funny
i was just thinking about you
or they just know who it is when the
phone
rings before they've looked at the
caller id or answered it with the phone
it's very very common experience um it
works
especially well with people who know
each other well telepathy is about
people who are bonded socially now
for a hundred years or more since the
invention of the telephone
people have observed this but the
so-called skeptics
the dogmatic skeptics have said oh well
it's impossible that it's really
telepathy that can't happen because
minds are just inside brains
it's impossible for them to have an
influence at a distance it's nothing but
coincidence and selective memory you
remember when you're right you forget
when you're wrong and so on
anyway i've developed a test to test
that
and how the test works is you register
on my website
sheldrate.org you put in the names of
two
friends or family members people you
know well and their telephone numbers
the computer then at a randomized time
picks one of these two people at random
calls them up
so say i was doing the test and you were
one of my callers
yeah so my wife jill was the other one
and you get a call saying this is
rupert's
telephone telepathy test please think
about rupert when you're ready
press one you press one my phone then
rings
the corner id says telephone telepathy
test
it says one of your two corners is on
the line right now waiting to speak to
you
press one for alan press two for jill
so i then say who i think it is out of
these two people
and as soon as i guess that's recorded
on a database
the line opens up and i get instant
feedback
as to whether i'm right or wrong and
then i can talk for up to a minute it
cuts off after a minute because i'm
paying for the call
and
and um this test is giving you know
very significant positive results in in
my earlier versions of the test i had
four callers
and there the chance rates 25 and we
were getting
uh rates at average rates of about 45
percent
you know with hundreds wow massively
significant statistically
yeah and this so this uh what i'm trying
to do at the moment
is to find out if people can get better
at this by practice
and if so how they practice how they can
develop their intuition
so what i'd like to say to anyone
listening to this is if you're in the
u.s
canada or uk or italy the test doesn't
work anywhere else at the moment
um then check it out try it with your
friends it doesn't take very long
about 10 minutes for your time to do one
of these tests spray spaced over an hour
and a half or a couple of hours
and um this if
i'm inviting people to try and find how
to train their intuition
i don't know how to train me i'm not
that good at these things i score above
chance but i'm not brilliantly intuitive
so i'm asking other people to help with
this and and
in fact it could turn into a competition
who's got the best intuition
yeah a global competition and they
it could even end up if people find they
can practice and get better at it
it could even end up with a telepathy
olympics olympics
who's the most telepathic person in the
world yeah
and then i think when we get to that
stage all these boring old skeptics who
just know it
possible the evidence isn't there it
doesn't exist this would i mean
they'd still exist but they'd become
like the flat earth society
yes fringe group they are a fringe group
anyway but
they pretend they speak for the the
science establishment they don't really
but they pretend to
anyway here's a way forward
yeah yeah this yeah that that you're
what you just
summarized there with the joint
detention study in the telephone
telepathy study
was basically the essence of what i was
getting at with
actually when you plant a flag beyond
the edge
and then further is you actually you
yourself
create the tests to further prove
the hypothesis and then try and inspire
other people around the world to not
only create
not only participate in your test but
also create their
own tests to try and prove these
hypotheses
and also i actually really appreciated
the
i think the structure of the two
that you spoke about it's very important
first of all the joint
attention study i i really like how
for both of them that you can
crowdsource people from
around the world well us uk
and uh australia and it in italy
italy that's the telephone one the joint
attention test works everywhere so
everywhere so so this is this is a big
deal because if you can get people from
india and brazil and russia and all
these other countries around the world
that are
that can that can do the
uh you know joint detention one and
beyond let's see if we can get people
around the world doing
these i appreciate how i think the
structure rupert that you were
describing
as somebody that is also a fellow
science scientist science advocate
science communicator
um it's just for me to for me to view
the the style of your experiments
it sounds quite robust and in the sense
of
um uh even getting even getting small
incremental differences of training
intuition
you can't you can't pick up a basketball
and just walk onto a court and start
shooting three-pointers you can't pick
up a violin
and just start playing mozart you you
you have to train your intuition
you have to train these telepathic
abilities in order for you to
bump up like if in that example where
there's you know
four in telephone telepathy if there's
four options of my four
friends and if on my rate is only
supposed to be 25 but if i'm hitting
45 that's significant and that's also a
big deal
if i'm um slowly trying to compete if
i'm becoming
the united states best uh most intuitive
telephone telepathist and then i'm
competing against
the united kingdoms and germany's and
and china's and i think that's a very
interesting style of of trying to you
know if
if rupert if we can take that flag
beyond the edge of what's known and if
we can
incentivize people to partake through a
sports
style olympic style process
like what you're teaching i think that's
also very fun and it's engaging
and also the joint detention thing has a
lot to do with the modern
day uh we're approaching all eight
billion people soon to be connected
on the planet and if you can release a
piece of content
and then watch how people
watch the content and if they can tell
if they're if other people that they're
engaging with if this person if
if rupert is also watching the um the
advancement that's been made in biotech
or if rupert's watching the advancement
that's being made in blockchain and
cryptocurrency and then
i pick which one rupert's you know
watching
and i think that's very interesting
given the fact that all eight billion
people are now
we can there's a collective zeitgeist
that's happening
all the time with this pacer of the
cycle of media absolutely
well i think this is that's why i think
it's so topical at the moment the whole
question of joint attention
there's never been a capacity for so
many people
to have so much joint attention and
now everyone agrees of course that we're
interlinked through the internet and
through news media and through radio and
television and so forth
but the big blockage to these inquiries
within
institutional science is this
materialist assumption the mind's
nothing but the brain
and that's why no one's doing research
on this
um it's also one reason why i've
uh i like doing research in the public
domain
and i like doing it outside universities
and where anyone can take part
but it's also that i'm forced to work
that way because these
subjects are so taboo there's almost no
university where you could actually do
this
research and hold down a job and you
know
because the the opposition to these
things is is very very strong
from dogmatic materialists i mean most
ordinary people are not opposed most
ordinary people are
interested in these phenomena but within
the academic world there is this problem
of
dogmatic materialism anyway i
tried just to get a go go on doing
research and and get on with these
experiments
there's enough people who participate uh
for the results to come in
and of course uh morphic resonance
experiments are also
possible in the human realm um
it's it's hard to set up morphic
resonance experiments online because
what you're trying to do in morphic
resonance is seeing if a skill gets
easier as time goes on
is it getting easier to learn
skateboarding windsurfing snowboarding
skydiving etc the problem is in real
world grouper could it be something like
teaching a brand
could it be like a brand new sport
because skateboarding and all these
other sports are
already they're known but if we made up
a new sport in some random location
across the planet
and then the general idea is that if i
picked
people of approximately same cognitive
capacity
and in in one part of the planet and we
taught them a brand new never been
thought of before sport
and then we picked other people of the
general similar cognitive capacity
and we when we measured the time that it
took them to learn this brand new sport
that no one's ever heard of
and that's the idea of how we could do
that absolutely they should be able to
learn it quicker
but the problem is you know i spend a
lot of time thinking about experiments
and
the the problem with this particular one
is that now
everything is so interconnected with the
internet that
if you train a group of people and you
say look we're training you this really
new sport no one else has ever done in
the world
within seconds one of them is going to
have it on instagram hey guys i'm
learning this place for sport
um the only way of actually doing this
would be to have a group of people who
really are cut off
from the rest of the world you know
prisoners for example
or have it done right away like if you
if you take
and just and you ask them hey guys just
for the rest of the day
don't um post about this on on the
internet quite yet
even though that is like our extended
phenotype in a sense but just
don't post about it on the internet yet
and then have the group in
you know if we're doing this in texas
and then we have somebody
in oxford and somebody in melbourne that
it that are that are also going to do it
just
literally 15 minutes after the one in
texas completed
yeah that's good a good idea and
actually where this would
probably be it would probably be easiest
to do using some kind of new video game
which involves some kind of new skill
that you have to learn to do the video
game
so this could be built into some kind of
new gaming platform
um where you could have a completely new
thing in a video game whether you have
to solve particular problems
um that um no one solved before
and then it might be possible to get
people doing it you know
15 minutes later in melbourne australia
and that sort of thing
um and see if they do it quicker okay
like
like a sort of in in a sense it would be
like if i'm entering into a game because
i'm a huge
i'm a huge gamer um and have been and
i think a lot of people around the world
are because it kind of creates a
an idea of a deeper idea about who we
truly
are and how this is already virtual
reality but we'll get there in a moment
the idea is that it could be the
immersion into a game where
i have to do a never-before-done
puzzle of sorts and i and i do that
never before done
puzzle and then immediately as soon as
i'm done they're triggered in a
different country around the world the
next person begins doing the puzzle
then the next person and these are
gamers that have generally the same
cognitive capacity
and generally the same uh dexterity and
video game
um uh capacities their their abilities
have been trained
so it's not like somebody that has never
held a game controller before versus
somebody that has
yeah that's right well maybe the beer
people who do this might have to do some
kind of preliminary test to show that
they're up to a certain level of skill
yes um or there are certain games have
levels anyway
pick people who are at a certain level
um
anyway the point is with large samples
it doesn't really
matter about matching them too much you
can do things with
you know if you've got thousands of
people taking part
yeah the individual differences tend to
cancel out with very large samples
as long as there's not a systematic bias
in favor of
smart people doing it first and less
smart people doing it later
so rupert would you say that um i see
where i see where you're going there
that's that's beautiful so
the idea is that if we could recruit
just uh
a thousand people around the world to to
do
the same puzzle that's never been done
before
but that we make this we design this
puzzle and then we kind of have a domino
effect of the 1000 people in different
countries around the world as soon as
the first person's done
it's a brief puzzle maybe it only takes
a minute um to get it done or two
minutes or whatever
and then the next person starts it the
next person starts as soon as the other
one finishes
and the idea would be that generally
speaking
it should be if the first person takes
four minutes to get it done
by the end of the 1000 the last person
should be getting it done in one minute
or something like that there should be a
significant increase
well it would be the points would be
scattered you know it would be like
drawing a graph through scattered points
you know the statistical techniques tell
you if you can see a significant trend
would there be a significant trend
towards it getting easier
you can statistics enables you to deal
with individual differences when you're
looking for trends
so you'll be looking for a trend and
then
i mean the more people the better
actually if you're doing
the trend i mean there is i i think this
would be
a a brilliant way of testing morphic
[Music]
i'm not a gamer myself and i don't know
people who
program games but i can help
i can help yeah i rupert the reason why
we
you know we have these conversations
also is not only for people
to get um inspired about pushing
beyond the edge of what's known like
what you're doing and
signing up at sheldrake.org for the
joint detention study and the telephone
telepathy study
but also you know for them to design the
games
and then for them to do these new
studies
around the world that can begin proving
this rupert we're gonna carry
the flag very strong moving forward and
and and i agree that i think through
games especially
i mean there's so many uh
even in the last five years there's so
many i know that
um you know stanford and harvard and uh
ucsf and so many places
around the world have started doing
where you just take your
your device you you take you take your
device
and it's something as simple as just
getting that
that uh that notification that there's
a new game that a new puzzle
where we're doing a test of morphic
resonance and and
you know you get the notification and
and you and you do the
you do the puzzle and you're part of the
study and you might get paid
you know uh five bucks for participating
it because we got
a grant from an ultra high net worth
family around the planet that is very
interested
in this exact phenomenon and so
this is the future that we're ushering
and this is a big central part of
of this project and so it's totally
available today
to do things like that oh great well i
mean
anything you can do to help this along
alan would be very very welcome that
would be great
um i think this would be uh
astonishingly interesting
yes we have the tools now to to do so
um rupert i have a guys a call to action
get something like this out into the
world faster
um and and uh and let's find out these
these what's beyond the edge of what's
currently known and let's test it
scientifically and in a fun and engaging
way like through
like through solving puzzles and games
and things like that this is a really
fun part of
of the conversation rupert rupert i have
a i have a couple more um
quick questions that i i would like to
ask you um
all right okay okay cool um if
our nature of reality
is truly the one
indivisible
indescribable um whole
that we are and that the nature of
reality is truly that consciousness that
is experiencing itself across
these 8 billion dissociative boundaries
and that the the idea then would be
i'm curious what you think would it be
fair to use an analogy
like a dreamed symphony been playing
around with this i'm curious what you
think
that we are that that
that unity that unity of a symphony and
that
each one of us in the symphony is
playing a different instrument i'm
playing
the cello you're playing the clarinet
someone else is playing the sax someone
else the drums
and that we're even people that are
playing the same instrument are playing
different melodies or harmonies and that
actually your son
right cosmo's a musician right yes
yeah okay and so the the idea is that
if i'm if and by the way the conductor
is like
uh is an attractor so there's like a you
know the the mathematical system
there's a mathematical attraction for
our complex system to evolve towards
this attractor which which could be like
a oroboros or something like uh you know
an automata orthogenesis to uh
recursive function or something but the
point is is that like
is the dream symphony analogy a good way
for us to understand like if i'm playing
more out of
tune let's say my cello i'm playing more
out of
tune that's because i'm serving to
myself
but if you're playing your clarinet and
you're playing it in tune
that's because you're playing service to
other and so the other
so the idea is that we are going through
some sort of a
a dreamed symphonic uh
artistic oneness
evolution and that we can both integrate
into the symphony and differentiate
like in calculus of our
unique contribution how do you how does
that
dream symphony analogy for the nature of
reality resonate
well it does rather assume that
everything
is working together to start with i mean
a symphony orchestra
they have to have a shared agenda to
play to have a symphony together
and
excuse me um it's
it's not um immediately obvious that
there is at least as far as a whole of
humanity is concerned
uh a shared symphony i mean the
president of the united states and
you know the various figures and islamic
fundamentalist movements et cetera
i mean the the there's so many different
points of view
the you know hindu nationalists in india
you know chinese asserting their power
etc
it's not clear that everyone sees
themselves as part
of a coordinated symphony of humanity
um and for the dream symphony to
i think people would have to sign up to
be part of a dream symphony orchestra
um for this particular metaphor to work
uh it's not obvious that's the case um
you could argue that there are
underlying creative forces that i mean i
myself think there are
um working through history and that
conflict
is part of it and that the conflict
plays its part in the creative
evolution of things i mean a personal
example
when my book uh sunset free came out
my ted talk my tedx talk in 2013 the
called the science delusion uh was taken
down by ten from their main website
because of protests from militant
materialists ps ed myers and jerry coyne
who are both
militant richard dawkins type
materialists
and ted tried to suppress this
talk or at least hide it completely
unsuccessfully
and but this attack from these people
who wanted to
stop me having a platform led to
enormous controversy on the internet
the result is that at least six million
people have seen this talk now
whereas before their protests only about
30 000 had seen it
so um they were playing their part and
you know i don't have
a kind of personal hostility to people
like
jerry coyne and stuff i mean they're
playing their part in this drama
but dream symphonies also include
dissonances
i mean music's not all harmony and you
know
it's the dissonance is a part of it
so it may be that there that jerry coyne
is part of this dream symphony without
realizing it
um so okay okay so so it could
also be fair to say that not only is it
that
we may have different national
agendas across the planet uh
in parts of the symphony but also just
that in general
um within the symphony the playing out
of tune is not only when you're trying
to like
hoard things in service to self
mentality
but it's also when you are um being
militant
in one specific dogma and
yeah i i think that's very interesting
thank you for pointing that out
yes okay and of course people may also
play altitude out of sheer incompetence
so um
rupert um i want to ask you on a on a um
on a
telos perspective um
given the fact that artificial
intelligence is now
significantly for deeper emergence so
are virtual realities which are kind of
in a sense when you when you immerse
yourself in one for an extended period
of time
you in a sense could say that holy cow
how am i not already in one how is this
not already one
so we have ai we have vr we have
simulation technology simulation theory
could it be that where these
technologies
are are triangulating on the same thing
in the sense that the eastern
spirituality has been saying for the
longest time that
the dreamer the ultimate dreamer of
infinite consciousness
ends up uh in this dream that we're in
now
wakes up and then goes right back into
another dream as in
the oroboros continues so is the west
what is the telos is the west focus on
aivr
simulation tech could that be what john
smart calls the transcension hypothesis
when we go
inward into these substrates and that we
uh continue the oro boros and that we
keep
going through more and more big bangs
and that that is our
in that is our uh that that's our
attractor
is that the tilos what do you think
about that
well i think that there's there's a
sense in which artificial intelligence
virtual reality
you know are expanding the realm uh
certainly of what machines can do and
also
of things like games and whatnot um
i think there's a parallel exploration
going on
which is non-technological through this
the um renewed research on psychedelics
because psychedelics after all a way of
opening up the imaginal world
particularly the visionary ones i mean
ayahuasca
lsd mushrooms and so on which have
uh an enormously liberating effect on
the imagination for many people
um i mean they're not for everyone and
i'm not advocating indiscriminate use of
psychedelics and especially not
encouraging people to do anything
illegal i mean i have to say these
disclaimers
um but the fact is that um
as well as this exploration um we've
also got a parallel exploration going on
and in fact in places like silicon
valley the
exploration through psychedelics um is
often happening in the same people
who are engaged in in the especially in
computer graphics um and visualizing
things and virtual reality
so i think here we've got this
expanded range of explorations
that aren't based on technology i mean
personally i think they're more fun when
they're not based on technology i mean
i'm not
very technological myself um but i think
there's
exploration of consciousness which after
all has happened in the east
through meditative techniques it's
happened
in the west through meditative
techniques i mean contemplative
christianity in the middle ages and
since then in the
catholic and the orthodox tradition of
monks and nuns
living in enclosed orders some of them
spend hours a day in
meditation and prayer and they're
exploring realms of consciousness
and they're not just exploring their own
consciousness the whole point is that
through meditation and these spiritual
practices
you come into contact with other forms
of consciousness
that's the whole point of my recent
books and the most recent one being
ways to go beyond and why they work
seven different spiritual practices
um uh which have been scientifically
investigated
and are about exploring these realms of
consciousness
beyond our normal everyday consciousness
so i think what's exciting at the moment
is there's a new phase of spiritual
evolution beginning
through the widespread availability of
spiritual practices
and scientific studies of them and also
all these amazing technological uh
adventures and i think that they're
complementary i don't think it's one or
the other
yeah there's a big convergence that is
happening there
and whatever the telos uh ends up being
wherever the
tractor of the complex system is heading
it's inevitably
it in order to be happy and have great
well-being and have good amounts of
peace
and collective prosperity and individual
flourishing
one needs to embody what you write about
in ways to go beyond where you
where you talk about specifically um
also
the practices of doing things like
meditation
i think people also forgot that even the
word yoga
means union in sanskrit it's not holding
stretching positions
and it means union with the divine
whatever your unique
combinatoric is with the divine
and also gratitude is such a a prominent
one
that is so important and it's the way
that science and spirituality are
converging which you've written about so
much
um going out in nature um very
very very last thought is um you are the
fifth
person now including let's see here dr
aubry de gray
um dr robert ajimian dr kirill
piazzkevich
uh and jonathan keats and now dr rupert
sheldrake
i'm trying to keep a list of these
people because
you guys are the only people that i know
that do not
own cell phones and
what what you have you have said
well uh i'll say what you know aubry de
grey has called it the ultimate
destroyer of personal solitude
you have said i do not want to be
interrupted all the time
and for example with me this device has
been off
now for quite a long period of time so
that i can finish this project and it's
going to be off
so that i can continue finishing this
project so
will you please briefly speak to
especially the millennial and generation
z
that is now using the devices non-stop
we use them 150 times a day
we speak to the importance and cal
newport talks a lot about the idea of
deep work
and we've been talking about this for so
long but just the focus
and neurobiologists are talking about it
now the importance of that focus for
achieving big goals in your life
will you just briefly mention um talk
about that for a moment
well yes i mean phones are obviously
highly convenient and
they're essential for many people's work
life and and so they
obviously have their uses um
but they can easily become a means of
constant distraction
and the whole point of um deeper work is
being able to focus and concentrate and
constant distraction of
drip feed of news and social trivia on
facebook and other social media and
so um is just ultimately distracting
and so i think that one one of the
things i suggest actually in
ways to go beyond i have a chapter there
on the importance of holy days and
festivals
um and it was always a tradition
and in in the jude in the judaic
tradition having the sabbath a day when
you don't work
the whole point of the sabbath is that
you it's a day
it's a holy day a holy day is a holiday
this is the same word
yeah you you it's a holy day because you
don't work
and then the purpose of it is to give
thanks to god
to make love to be with your family to
play music
to have fun and then
for christians it's sunday for muslims
it's friday but there's like this
pattern
of a sabbath the day in the week when
you have we now have a weekend
two days but the trouble is these have
now got engulfed by 24 7 culture
so shopping malls are open or at least
they were until the coved lockdowns
and you know constant amazon deliveries
online shopping 24 7.
this is completely abolished this
necessary
time it's part of human nature to have
time off
together and for people who are forced
to work on sundays because they work in
a shop in a shopping mall for example
then the employer says oh you can have
tuesday off instead that's not the point
because everyone else is working on
tuesday it's it's being together
being alone altogether as one wishes to
have a time away
from all this work life and
the the workaholic culture which america
has spread to the rest of the world
[Laughter]
procedures uh i mean america is the
place where it's worst i think
workaholism
um is uh really does need something
doing about it for our own sanity
and so i think that the minimum thing
i'd suggest is having as a technological
sabbath i mean ideally on
if you're jewish on saturday if you're
christian from a christian background on
sunday of your muslim background on
friday um
but have have a day when you don't work
when you do when you do just have time
to
read books listen walk in nature do some
gardening
hang out with friends make love uh play
music
uh you know and and not be distracted
the whole time
so i think that for people who need
these devices for their work
who've become dependent on them for
earning a living i mean
and many people have um obviously you
can't just give them up
but having a technological sabbath and
actually ideally combining with a real
sabbath
real um holy day once a week
and then observing the festivals i think
it's very important to
most people observe in america
thanksgiving and christmas
um but there are other festivals
throughout the year which are important
and
for me an important one is september the
29th the feast of st
michael and all angels which is a time
to become aware of all those forms of
consciousness beyond the human level
and the ancients thought that every star
and planet had its own
intelligence which was an angel i mean
they weren't
humanoid beings with wings they were the
intelligences of the celestial bodies
the whole heavens is full of
intelligence in that worldview
and for me the feast of michael and all
angels is a way to connect with all
those forms of non-human
intelligence beyond our own the feast of
the day of the dead
um november the second which is a very
big deal in mexico
and in many catholic countries um is the
feast
when we acknowledge and remember the
ancestors those who've gone before
november the 1st all saints day all
hallows day
is when we remember the blessed dead in
the famous dead and
november the second everyone else and
for most people they're just forgotten
about these festivals
instead children remember the eve of
these festivals halloween
um that's become a sort of orgy of
dressing up as witches
and and eating candies and stuff um
but the festival itself has been
hollowed out and
for me again november the second is a
day when i
i always go to a requiem mass i remember
my dead parents and ancestors my dead
friends and all those i know
and who will give thanks for who've gone
before on november 1st
i give thanks to all those who've been
my teachers who are now departed and
who've influenced me
so i think having throughout the year
you see there are these special days the
festivals
each with its own purpose and their
holidays traditionally
um so that there's time to give
attention to these other things
so i think recovering a sense of sacred
time
yes is very important and switching off
cell phones uh when one's doing that
is is a very important part of it so i
would say that
starting the special days holy days and
festivals
um and then maybe extending it out
further
to only having it on certain hours a day
it would be a good way to go it's not a
good way to go to have one's entire life
engulfed by 24 7 workaholic culture
so well said these technological
sabbaths also these rituals that have
been passed on for so long to have
like you talk about the brief moment
before you dig into your
dinner and with your family just hold
each other's hands and close your eyes
and reflect on the beauty
of the fact that you are sharing a meal
there's so many different ways there's
all these
days that are celebratory days to just
take a sabbath away from
technology and workaholism and just tune
more
inward and music make love
um go play be in nature do art
um this is so beautiful and
i'm really happy that that you listed i
i it's gonna be really important
potentially even moving forward to do
things like
just have a have date have more days
where we just
say okay turn down
the economic machinery today and turn
up the spiritual machinery today
we're going to have to have more days
like that in the future that was
beautifully said rupert thank you
so much for coming onto the program
and for uh teaching us everything that
you have today this has been an honor
and a pleasure
we're very grateful thank you oh fun to
be with you alan thank you
thank you thanks everybody for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we would
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode
with rupert please let us know what
you're thinking about all the different
things that rupert was teaching about
and talking about
we would love to hear your thoughts on
those things you can also find all the
links in the bio below to sheldrake.org
also um on sheldrick.org you can find
all of his different
books that he's authored and co-authored
go check those out
rupert also has the the joint attention
study
as well as the telephone telepathy study
for you to go and participate in
go and participate in those and actually
go and share those around the world get
more people participating in them
and then also make your own studies like
we were talking about regarding
like things like puzzle video games guys
let's go do that around the world those
are going to be important
check out rupert's youtube channel he's
constantly uploading more and more
great content on there um did you have
something you wanted uh
to briefly say about the studies
no i think that's so fine you've you
covered practically everything alan
thank you
okay okay excellent excellent yeah good
um and
that's that's it uh support the artists
the entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
the scientists in your communities
that you believe and support them and
help them flourish you can support
rupert you can support ourselves and
and the simulation in our show all of
our links are in the bio below
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much
thank you for tuning in we will see you
soon
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you